goo
[音楽]
私は母ですそしてモンテッソーリ教育の教師です
何歳から小学生の子どもたちに
モンテソーリメソッドを使った英語学習を行っています
誰もが幸せになりたい
豊かに行きたいと思っています
子どもたちには自分たちよりも良くなってほしい
という願いがあります
親は子どもが小さいときから
様々な経験ができるよう考え悩みます
泳げるようになってほしい
英語が話せるようになってほしい
ムードはね心も鍛えてほしい
お部屋の願いはさておき
子供の時から様々な経験ができるということはとても幸せなことです
人生はそんな経験の旅の連続だという人もいます
では
私たちは子どもより良くしていくために
どんな旅ができるのでしょうか
赤ちゃんはめまぐるしく発達し成長します
この世界のあらゆることを吸収し
全ての感覚をフルに使って感じ
大人の真似をして
宇宙になってできることを増やします
5歳くらいまでにはのの基礎の80%ほどが完成し
その後の人生はそれまでに培ってきたものをベースに生きていくのだそうです
そんな子どもの様子を100年前
研究し続けたある女性がいました
女性にまだ選挙権がなかった時代です
イタリアデー
初めての女性の医師になったまりやモンテソーリという人です
ユーロになる前のイタリアの船尾だ冊に彼女の肖像画が描かれていました
彼女は子どもの知的好奇心をよく研究しました
観察もしました幼い子どもがどのようにしたら
今一番伸ばしたいところを伸ばせるのか
幸せに生きていくためには大人がどんな炎上すればいいのか
当時はテーブルや椅子もまだ子供サイズのものは無かった時代
子供は騒がしく何もできない存在だから大人の言う通りにしていればいいと
追われていました
ところが彼女は
あたりバン bb という子供のための家を作り
日常で使う道具を子供サイズのものに作り変え
やりたいことを自分で選んでできるようになるための環境をつくりました
大人の価値基準ではなく子どもの目線から彼らの好奇心に応える活動を考え出したの
です
大人は教える人
ではなく
子供の水から伸びる力を信じてその力が発揮できるよ
援助する人
と考えるのがモンテッソーリ教育です
文化や習慣が違っても子どもの成長のプロセスは何百年経っても変わりません
子どもの育ちをよく理解し主体的に取り組める環境をつくり
集中してできたという達成感とともに
子どもの成長を支えるこの教育法は
100年以上経った今でも世界中の多くの人々に広く支持されています
私は教育を学びましたが
モンテソーリ教育にね
子どもをよく観察するようになりました
よく観察することで思いもよらないことが起こるのです
私には8歳の息子がいます
彼は去年の春休みにこんなものを作りました
なんでしょうね
その日私は皿洗いをしていました頭の中でいつものようにやるべきことを色々考え
いると
あああああ
見て3 day
勝規定トゥ
私を呼ぶ声が聞こえてきたのです
あなたならどうしますか
私は今お皿笑っているからこれが終わったら行くネット伝えようと思ったら彼は待ち
きれません
私のところにこれを持ってきてまあまあ
デロリアン作ったよ
入って見せてくれました
デロリアン
そう
映画ば苦痛だフィーチャーに出てくるあのタイムマシーンのデロリアンを作ったという
のです
裏を見ると
タイヤが注入口
ワーリングタイプになっています
白昼大フューチャー do のタイプです
私は思わずいいのができたんじゃないと彼に伝えました
すると軽い
あっちにもデロリアン作ったよええ
いって彼の食卓の椅子を見せてくれました
デロリアンの運転席です
僕もマーティーみたい back to the future したいなと彼が言い
ました
そんな時です私はビビッとひらめきました
そして瞬時に大答えました
できるよ
ウェン使う back to do
スコアえっという顔で私を見ていました
次の日
私たちはとてもワクワクしていました急いで博多駅に行って吉報会
なんと
デロリアン電車に乗り込んだのです
バックトゥー打球チャー3のタイプです
nedo の時代に行くのインディアンの時代それとも1985年
彼がずーっと聞いてくるので私はそうね
2000年前ぐらいかなと言いました
そんな昔
彼のテンションは max です
ついたところはのどかな風景が広がっていました
その中を20分ほど歩いていくと
とうとう2000年前に着いてしまったのです
さあ
現代の弥生時代吉野ヶ里遺跡
組で囲いがしてある収録の集落の門をくぐると目の前には高い櫓そしていくつもの竪穴
式住居が
あり当時の弥生人の暮らしが一面に広がっていました
私たちは
油を登ったり
竪穴式住居に入ったり出たりを繰り返しながら当時の住まいがなかなか快適だという
ことを知りました
案件をしているといろんな疑問もわいてきます
門のところに必ずある
とっ
木でできた鳥の飾りは何だろう
当時のトイレはどこにあったんだろう
意識をする神殿はどうして住居から随分離れたところにあったんだろう
私もわからないのでボランティアのおじさんに聞きに行きました
ちなみにトイレの後はまだ
使っていないんだそうです
遺跡探検のほかにも審議はをと書かれた民間を作ったり
県間も作りました
デロリアンから始まったタイムスリップの旅は筆のまにか
弥生時代へのキョンと変わっていったのです
帰りの電車の中で私は彼にこう伝えました
今日作った本物抜きんが福岡市の博物館にあるよと
すると彼はぜひそれを見たい
地盤が作ったものと比べたいと言い出したのです
次の日
今度はデロリアン池電車に乗って私たちは福岡市の博物館まで行きました
彼は持ってきた自分で作った
変換を取り出して
ショーケースの中の方
本物と
に比べ始めました
色
形
裏に印字されたもし
とってに付いた蛇の
レプリカを使って重さをタン体感したり面倒番人をしてみることもできました
驚いたことに彼は
自分で持ってきたノートを取り出して
色々とメモをし始めたのです
臣民の重さ10円玉
24枚分
とっての蛇以外に
かめや馬ラクダの模様が中国にはあった
事物を見ている間私は自分から彼に声をかけませんでした
私の余計なひと言で
彼の集中を妨げたとなかったからです
呼ばれたら反応し聞かれたら答えました
教え込みたい気持ちも売った葉がしました
彼が自分で発見し考えるチャンス
奪いたくなかったから
ある程度見終わった後に
私が気づいたことは伝えました
この
15ページにもおよぶ大辞典できた
ノードを見て分かる通り
この日私の出番はあまりありませんでした
デロリアンをきっかけにバックトゥーでフューチャーという視点から
2000年前の人々の暮らしに出会っ
そしたら興味が湧いてもっと知りたくなった
ほんのちょっとの
工夫と
出会い方次第で
自由で創造的な
探求の旅をあれば
始めたんです
私は子どもを観察しながら
100年前にありゃモンテソーリが入った
言葉の意味を思い出しました
子供には
自己教育力があると
さて
これらの出来事は私の息子だったからできたのでしょうか
私だったから短径体験したのでしょうか
いえすべてのお父さんお母さん
子どもに関わる人たちができることなのです
まずは子どもをよく観察してみてください
彼らが今
何に興味があるのか
どんなところを伸ばしたいのか
その答えは
彼らの中にあります
そして子どもの行動面白がってみてください
ほんのちょっと秒やすい
同じ視点に立ってみると
あまで言えなかったことっ
私たちが気付きます
私たちがいつのまにか子供から学びを経ているのです
大人の都合はいったん
秋においてみましょう
子供に敬意をもって接してみてください
強制したり
支配したり
否定したり
おしい込んだ
ということではなく
彼らがやりたいことを自分で選んでできるチャンスを与えてください
子供のゆっくりとした育ちを
理解し信じるのです
自分から始めたことにはやる気があります
やる気があると試行錯誤して考えます
考えてできたと喜びを味わうと
自分の事が
好きになるのです
これはこれから幸せな人生を歩んでいくための大きな原動力となるのです
私もどうしたらいいがよくわからず
を作している時に子供がたくさんのヒントを与えてくれました
そしてゆっくりとじっくり
忍耐強く
柔らかい心を持って
子どもと関わっていける自分自身をまずは準備して育てようと思ったかです
このことを常に意識していると
自分が変わり
目の前の子どもが
あっていきました
スコアその後お父さんと二人で北海道へ行きました
そして北海道にはなんと弥生時代がなかったことを私に教えてくれました
同時に彼だけの宝物をたくさん拾ってきました
それをみんなにも紹介したいと自分で考え
挑戦し
僕と根室の宝物という
小さな展覧会を福岡市のあるバストいう写真館
介在し
友達や
その後両親先生方や
カメラマンデザイナーなどなど
たくさんの人たちと自分の視点を共有しました
私たちは今でも
9枠とした
出会いの旅を続けています
やりたいこと
好きなことを
見つけるための
ために
あるから
ありがとうございます
[拍手]